hello everybody my name is markiplier
and it's time once again to gather even
more evidence that I am actually an
idiot and I am an idiot because I'm
actually playing more of the impossible
quiz after the embarrassment of the
first round now you may be wondering to
yourself while you're sitting in your
comfy chair at home not having to stress
about the problems of what's before you
we're markiplier why didn't you it's the
first one well kind viewer of which I
love so much let's just assume that I
reached the limit of my own intelligence
and I wasn't gonna be able to do it
anyway so let's just carry on into a new
set of questions to embarrass myself
with number one where does it general
keep his Army's sleeve ease even I know
that one which of the following do you
need to build a greenhouse I'm assuming
that the color of the house would not
matter and some people would vodka
definitely is what's necessary for this
quiz why paint why paint you it doesn't
matter when you're building it ok
nevermind you know what I'm not thinking
laterally I'm thinking a logically here
which is the largest Earth Mars Milky
Way galaxy I'm assuming the Milky Way is
the candy bar and that's a mars bar is
there a galaxy bar this is built in the
UK I don't know if there's like some
galaxy candy I'm gonna assume that
that's a candy bar yeah I got your
number
oh wait oh oh I did one of these before
it was the dancing bomber or the bun
that I don't remember but can can't
happy 10 Christmas spirit American
American a merry um a merry can of Mary
isn't happy because the brace people
they say Mary no we say Mary too but I
[Music]
press C hey RR o T tear it the one thing
that I didn't get in the last question
that I did over there how many letters
in this sentence
I'm assuming that you mean this sentence
wouldn't be 28 or 29
oh just in sentence cuz there's eight
over there
use the right key
you mean right isn't right
Boulder's in golden Harry just like your
gold and slightly hairy disgusting nose
is that is this um is this mucus
dripping off of your nostril the clue I
just need to know you're look rather
shocked and I don't really want to shove
anything into that weird mouth you got
there but destiny is what it is so oh
yeah well I mean I lost twice but I got
you eventually it was the right Mouse or
the right keyboard button where does the
Great Wall of China start what is so
painful what is happening to you why are
you the oh my okay oh you look so happy
now oh it's not a bad transformation
it's just oh look at you
whoa what happens if you put pick up a
penguin fills your stomach what is
penguin another British thing this was
made by UK people over in the land of
London and I have no idea what they're
talking about what happens if you put
pick up a penguin is this supposed to be
a tongue twister are you emphasizing the
P so they Eve Oh penguin poo because to
pees nope thank you feature
oh that was a lovely sound I have the
option to give up as well that's good
what the hell was that you want to try
that again
never mind where does he general keep
his armies in his sleeve ease
someone said also someone said I read
the comments a lot that I need to save
my skips because apparently at question
110 in last one you needed to use every
single skip that you ever had to be able
to win that's totally ridiculous
so he ridiculous okay it's either
nothing or it fills your stomach
oh no what happens if you pick to pick
up a penguin what is it wait a minute
what I press B it's not P what the hell
is it what do you want from me what are
you trying to say about Papa Papa Papa
look at Peppa Pig pick up a penguin how
do I pick up a penguin how I pick up
I pick up a penguin what they don't get
it there's no question there's no answer
it's not possible
why don't you do that to me it is
sleepies oh you tricky bastard how I
love you put your mouse on here
don't drop the key and don't try to
cheat okay
oh by the way you you guys can actually
see my mouse this time hopefully so that
was a complaint Oh answer this question
upside down okay answer this question
upside down okay
hang on everybody we're going for a
little bit of a ride here let's split it
up that down but that's backwards on the
all right why would I do that
other than wedded up my daughter whoa
Oh God blood to my head oh that that
shot of blood to my brain really
increased my intelligence by an enormous
amount not really ku comer all right
fine wait a minute
oh okay nevermind what do Germans water
their garden with Walltown de dólar
hosing you Rhine what's the German word
for water faster I'm gonna guess urine
[Music]
would it happen to be rain why later
hosing oh no if I just say the answers
out loud it gets much easier what is
this what am I doing here what do we got
oh I see how this is so I gotta find
where it fits and then douchenozzle over
the douchiness and then kick them all in
the butt and then hopefully go along my
merry way and never have to deal with
any of this crap ever again
click the UM click the question number
oh god I can't read that
it's click the good lordy loo what is
that hell doesn't want for me okay I'm
trying to read the click the oh okay
what's the question number okay yeah it
took me a while to see that Wow my brain
was not working click the question
number twice ah where is the question oh
okay
there was no cleaving what is God
Jesus's dad dog its dog backers there we
go oh shut up mom I don't want to talk
to you right now I shouldn't be so mean
to my mom sorry
okay what is the name of the impossible
quiz cat or Perl what happened
which wasn't paying attention sleepies
Brown okay brown brown brown brown just
trying to do what you wanted so it's not
cheese and I would guess that spider-man
is pretty cheesy hahahaha what does
spider-man's favorite food fly
sandwiches okay
all right what is this Oh Dino one of
those few stopper purple bastard bomb
blaster purple bat I feel like I have to
pronounce all these words very slowly
fee cyst a poor one a loon how many
question does the very first impossible
quiz app hundred ten
[Music]
[Music]
oh you ugly bastard what's with your
hair looks like just spider legs coming
out of the top of your head oh don't
give me no kisses okay how many
questions does the very first impossible
quiz have what is candy floss made out
of it
what's candy floss is that what you call
cotton candy in Britain land is that
what you think that is how about I
[Music]
forgot what this answer was enough nope
Wow wait what no what am I am i extra in
my Oh okay whose turn is it this is my
life now I'm devolved into tears because
I'm so stupid I get a good grades in
school why do I have to deal with this
bull honkey give me a clue what do I do
where do I go from here it's not very
clear
[Laughter]
you skip haha which of the following can
be found under the sea under the sea
nipples nipples nipples nipples I'm
gonna go with nipples it wasn't right I
would have been more upset if it was
right hmm under the Oh under the sea
under the sea under the sea are you
talking under the sea si si si si Senor
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what the hell that is what
I got it oh yeah don't know how to win
this one but I don't care cuz I'm a
winner
oh wait whoa whoa whoa which can be
found under the sea I don't care anymore
I got bad that was yeah yeah space Y Oh
space saw when is a door not a door
Oh when it's ajar as in a door being
ajar yeah I'm getting this I'm getting
it good the flock of seagulls approach
you what do you do scream fart on them
you have to fart pretty high run run so
far and I ran and IRA kick them through
a window punch their tiny kidneys that's
what I do I saw the green one oh I get
it I get it I get it I get it I'm just
supposed to put them all out okay
I get it I get it okay all right okay
okay okay yeah yeah I'm smart oh no I'm
not smart not smart did I get them all
Oh how many roles in a polo in how many
holes in a role oh how many how do you
get two whales in a car one in the front
and one in the back drive down the m4
British humor you're an idiot
how'd it go with that one okay I am
actually all out of time I'm sorry to
say I am literally all that time I a big
recording day with Bob Wade and someone
else that I got to get but I am done
here I am officially giving up my
intelligence has been beaten I am
officially an idiot and I don't think
that anyone could disagree with that
fact so thank you all so much for
watching if you want to see more of this
go boy
good for you good so anyway thank you
all again and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]